[Musik]
ich glaube dass wir eine sehr turbulente
zeiten kommen wir haben durchaus die
chance die zukunft so zu gestalten dass
sie erfreulich sein wird aber wir haben
einen harten weg dahin die größte
problem vor dem wir stehen ist der
klimawandel und die ökologische krise
aber wir werden auch politisch und
ökonomisch große umwälzungen bekommen
wir stehen am anfang des zweiten
maschinen zeitalters vieles was in
unserer gesellschaft selbstverständlich
war wird auf den prüfstand gestellt
ich könnte mir vorstellen das ist sehr
heftige ausschläge gibt ich habe angst
vor populismus habe angst vor unruhen
aber ich könnte mir vorstellen dass wenn
wir es richtig gut machen wir
berechtigte gründe haben können die
zukunft positiv zu sehen